THEN BILLY ALL GOING TO BE CANA
FOUL ON BRADLEY. SEE 74 AND A
HALF PERCENT. IT'S UP TO THE
HA
BARNES MAY BIGGER GU11 GAME LOS
STREAK IS OVER.
SPURUR
AND OUT OF BOUNDS.
TO THE RIM!
>> DROPPED THAT.
>> Referee: THERE'S NO ILLEGAL
CONTACT B
DRIVING.
MAXEY.
OKAY, THEY GO FOR THE TWO.
[Cheering and Applause].
MORE THAN ONE SHOT.
>> Matt: THERE IT IS. BASKET.
THERE YOU GO.
>> Matt: PA
GOOD NIGHT, PHILADELPHIA!
BACK TO JOKIC.
JOKIC.
THE SHOT CLOCK. AGREE.
JOKIC COULDN'T MOVE HIS FEET
QUICK ENOUGH TO GET
RATTLES OUT.
LOOSE BALL GRABBED BY TWO FOR T
NIK JOKIC.
TREES.
MARKKANEN.
HE KNOCKS IT DOWN.  SOME CLOCK
GARLAND IN TO MOBLEY.
MOTONIGHT.
>> John: NUGGETS NEED A THREE.
JOKIC.
TOOK IT INSIUT.
WORKING ON THE ROOKIE, MITCHELL.
FOUR ON THE CLOCK.
SABONIS HAS GONE TO THE L LER G.
.
AN OPPORTUNITY DAY, YOUNG ROLL,L
GET THE FOUL.
BRIDGES WITH THE MAKE.
AND KINGS WILL GET
NOW IT'S ABOUT THE DEFENSE. LIN.
JONES, ONE MITCHELL.
GET THE
FOULED.
AND HE WAS ABLE TO ESCAPE THE
TRIPLE TEAM AND GET
>> Eric: THE LAST TIME THEY
C.J.
McCOLLUM IS IN THE RUNNING. THE
HAVE NOW WON FIVE STRAIGHT  TIM.
FIFTEEN SECONDS.
PORTER DRIVES AND IT A  CUT IT
INTO HIS LEAD
OFFICIAL.
GET IT IN.
MAGIC TO
KNOCKS OFF STEVE KERR'S